this is possibly my favorite jordan
peterson clip ever
if you don't know Jordan Peterson he's
the University of Toronto professor who
I think that was on hiatus or at least
sabbatical from the University he came
to prominence because he was opposed to
this bill called c16 it was related to
transgender pronouns and for our
purposes today we don't even really have
to go that far back and give you the
full genesis of Jordan Peterson we're
here today and he's currently part of
this pseudo movement called the
intellectual dark web it's kind of a
movement even though it's not totally
clear everybody who's who's us
ostensively part of it acknowledges
being part of it I don't even know what
to call it I like calling it the
rebranding of bad ideas yes it's a
collective of sorts and he lectures
around the world sometimes with Dave
Rubin with different people so to cut
through the important thing for today
one of Peterson's big topics is that
forcing equality of outcome in our world
is unnatural and I actually agree with
him right and he goes further and says
that government and society should not
act to totally level out outcomes in a
forced way and he usually applies this
to things like affirmative action or
income distribution or equal pay between
men and women or other topics and I
don't totally disagree with him on this
issue in the sense that when you look at
any human endeavor there is a natural
distribution I don't know of any human
endeavor where everybody is the same
other than eventually everybody dies but
even on that people die at very
different ages and it different in
different circumstances so I agree with
him that totally enforcing like an
actual equality of outcome doesn't make
sense I focus on policies that would
ensure equality of opportunity the lots
of examples from him about this but he
is about equality of opportunity and not
equality of outcome one area that he is
also sort of making an aim in is the
topic of in cells and if you don't know
what in cells are in cell is sort of an
abbreviation of involuntarily celibate
it means you want to have sex but
involuntarily you're not able to find
someone to have sex with so you're not
having sex and to summarize Jordan
Peterson thinks that that's bad he says
it destabilizes society
he has sometimes pointed out that some
of the shooters and terrorists that have
committed horrible acts were in cells
and so he's floated this idea of trying
to correct the problem of people being
involuntarily celibate and I you can
characterize the plan in different ways
but the idea is to have some kind of way
were these guys who by virtue of the
free market are having a real hard time
generating of romantic encounters for
themselves they would somehow be able to
have sex and this is actually a form of
equality of that welcomed equality of
outcome which he claims to oppose and he
just about went wacky on the Joe Rogan
show until he realized how that's not
something he can really say because it
goes against everything he's been
arguing about for a year so here's one
example of how Jordan Peterson is
against enforcing equality of outcome
the really deadly leftist presumption is
equality of outcome right I think as
soon as you start talking about equality
of outcome you should be put in a box
and put off the shelf that's the but but
it isn't obvious why like that doesn't
sound like you know white people overall
it doesn't have the same guttural punch
that the excess of the right has right
so bear that in mind he he's clearly
against equality of outcome being the
sort of target for policy and here we go
check out this to understand what this
is going to be he now is talking about
how there is this uneven distribution of
sexual activity and there's some men
having a lot of sex and there's some men
having none at all
which of course when it's in economics
or academic achievement or creative
endeavors Jordan Peterson says it's
natural and healthy this is how human
endeavors organize themselves there's a
distribution and Joe Rogan points out
wait a wait a second if you want to
enforce some way for the in cells to
have sex it's kind of like the equality
of outcome you claim to oppose that's
what happens is that a small minority of
men have all the sexual opportunity a
fairly large minority of men don't the
women are on how because they can't find
a committed relationship it's bad for
most of the men and the men who have all
the sexual opportunity gets cynical but
this in some ways against your whole
idea of equality of outcome because
you're talking about equality of sexual
outcome now so now he's saying actually
I am NOT okay with unregulated
inequality when it comes to sexual
encounters we have to regulate or as he
calls it rectify it and this is the key
part if these men if you see that's
James that's the dominant basketball
player that just kicks everyone's ass
this is the this this is a guy who's
succeeded at the highest level right
well there's going to be people like
that
sexually there's going to be people that
are better at finding mates and that
this is what they enjoy they enjoy
having many mates they enjoy being yes
but but if this is what they enjoy if
it's a man who doesn't want a family and
enjoys dating multiple women why is that
bad well the I think the fundamental
reason it's bad is because it's bad in
the long run for children so he's saying
there is a broader reason why that's bad
it's bad that there's this uneven
distribution of outcomes when it comes
to finding people to have sex with and
then this is the key part this is the
key part where it looks like he almost
gets wait a second this is totally
antithetical to my views on equality of
outcome on just about every other issue
rectify that but how did you possibly
rectify that if one man is but like say
if we've got one six foot five beautiful
man who's got a perfect body and yet
brilliant and he just wants to date a
bunch of women yeah and all the rest of
the people or five foot one and they're
fat and they're lazy and like this guy's
gonna if this is the competition he's
going to win yep yep there's no way
around this and yeah even well let's
decide to have enforced monogamy where
becomes a popular thing the women are
going to be more drawn to him if he
chooses to date them they might decide I
would rather have him sometimes than
never is that actually what does happen
but what is wrong with that well what's
wrong with it is that it destabilized
society and it's bad for children right
you said that yeah but that's what if
they don't want to have children but
there's a lot of people that don't want
to have children there's a lot of people
that choose to go their entire life
without having children as men in their
30s some of my friends have vasectomies
they don't want children mm-hmm so why
why would that help in any way these
involuntary celibates well I think you
tilt the society so that it serves the
interests of well whoa whoa well I can't
say that you tilt Society so it serves
the greatest good so for example you
take from the rich and you give to the
poor to eliminate poverty which reduces
crime and increases life expectancy and
it's best for society as a whole but
it's not quite so good for those few
rich people who get the money taken away
this is like an aha moment where Jordan
Peterson realizes oh wait a second it's
totally antithetical to everything I've
been espousing and on which I've gotten
famous and I know that the Peterson
fanboys Pat they're gonna say I'm
misrepresenting what he meant
I'm mischaracterizing what he said I
lack the intelligent the intelligence to
even understand what argument it is but
this is by definition in forced monogamy
right or whatever solution he wants to
these in sells that ensures an unnatural
outcome which is much more equal than
what the free market of society would
dictate yeah there's really no defending
this and I think he was caught here
silver lining Jordan Peterson can admit
when he's wrong you know he did that
with the gay marriage cake debacle odium
Jeffries interview yeah didn't know that
so maybe you'll say that hey I didn't
think this one through and I've actually
come around and I realized that my views
here were inconsistent I'm already ready
and waiting ready and waiting any time
and he's welcome back on the program
anytime he was interviewed on this
program before by the way you can find
that online today's program sponsored in
part by movement watches and sunglasses
and women's bracelets now available at
MVM t.com slash Pakman many people when
they meet me the first thing they notice
is I'm much shorter than they assumed me
to be and then right after that they
noticed my watch from movement which
I've been wearing for a very very long
time now and the company has grown like
crazy while they have been sponsoring
the David Pakman show they've now sold
almost two million watches in over a
hundred and sixty countries watches
start at just 95 bucks the sunglasses
are great I've got a pair of the black
aviator style movement sunglasses and
they served me very well on my recent
road trip in California it's so sunny
there that the glare can really come at
you very surprisingly and the movement
sunglasses were absolutely fantastic and
we like to support companies with the
entrepreneurial spirit and with the
David Pakman show being an
entrepreneurial venture I am extra
pleased to continue to have movement as
one of our sponsors and I want to invite
you to save 15% with free shipping and
free returns at MVM t.com slash Pakman
they keep growing check out why by
checking out their expanding collection
at MVM t-dot-com
slash PA que ma n